no one imagines they'll have to do what
the LeBaron family did on Tuesday go to
the scene where three of their women and
six children among them baby twins were
shot down
[Music]
the surviving and injured children hid
for hours in the hills there in the US
getting treatment now there must be some
ethics I don't know there just has to be
justice here there does seem some
possibility of justice for them in
contrast to so many scenes across Mexico
because the LeBaron's are US citizens
that's why the Mexican Foreign Minister
was on the scene with other officials
they said this seems to be a case of
mistaken identity a gang thought the
family's cars belong to a rival group
they'd find the perpetrators they said
the government reiterates its conviction
and resolution so there won't be
impunity the problem is that in Mexico
near blanket immunity exists and has
done for years almost 90% of murders go
unsolved according to an independent
think-tank
and the countries suffering record
levels of violence on Tuesday president
Trump tweeted his solution war on the
cartels and promised us help in a phone
call to Mexican president Andres Manuel
Lopez Obrador
but Mexico stride all-out confrontation
before and it's only up the body count
there are not being jams we do not think
by riddling with bullets slaughtering
with the use of force with blood and
fire the problem will be resolved
he's instead betting on a long-term
strategy social programs that will give
the young and poor another option than
joining organized crime and in the short
term a new force called the National
Guard but although the National Guard's
been deployed its impact appears to have
been limited and its role unclear
meanwhile the government hasn't overly
focused on strengthening the
institutions that might be able to stop
him unity like the police public
prosecutors the judiciary but for now
the pressure to finally make Mexico
safer is not just coming from within the
country but from the powerful neighbor
to the north John Holman al-jazeera
Mexico City